und das ist der wahre Grund warum für
einen Hof kaufen also wir waren auch
früher mal in der Liebesbeziehung und da
gab es ja auch 1000 Spekulationen drüber
es kommt die Frage von der ich mich
gefürchtet habe wie viel hat der hoch
ungefähr gekostet ich habe euch gesagt
ihr sollt mir unangenehme Fragen zu
schicken und ich bereue es gerade schon
wieder aber ich werde mich den jetzt
stellen manche sind auch ganz lieb ich
ziehe jetzt in nicht mal einen Monat auf
einen Hof den ich gekauft habe und dazu
kam natürlich super viele Fragen also
fangen wir mal mit einer harmlosen Frage
an wie viel Grundstück habt ihr wollt
ihr mehr Tiere also es ist ein Resthof
ein sehr alter kleiner Resthof das
Grundstück ist ungefähr 5000
Quadratmeter groß ist ein ganz schön
großer Garten aber es ist jetzt nicht
kein riesengroßer Bauernhof also wir
werden da jetzt kein
landwirtschaftlichen Betrieb aufmachen
sondern das ist einfach ein
Selbstversorger Hof und ja wir wollen
mehr Tiere ich würde erstmal mit Schafen
anfangen weil ich will auch super gerne
wieder melken ich vermisse das so toll
unsere eigenen Milchprodukte herstellen
zu können also früher haben wir auch
unseren eigenen Käse gemacht eigenen
Joghurt ziegeneis selber gemacht
natürlich hatten wir unsere eigene Milch
und das ist einfach schon ein anderes
Level von Selbstversorgung und da will
ich auf jeden Fall wieder hin möchtest
du noch weitere Kinder also an sich
finde ich die Vorstellung richtig schön
noch mal Kinder zu haben ich habe bisher
nur einen Sohn der ist neun und der
super ich habe den mit 18 bekommen also
richtig früh ein Jahr vom Abi das hat
wundersamerweise alles sehr gut geklappt
so wie es war vor zwei Jahren habe ich
mich von seinem Papa getrennt wir
verstehen uns weiterhin gut und das ist
alles schön aber es war natürlich
trotzdem ganz schön hart die Familie zu
verlieren die wir uns versucht haben
aufzubauen ja ich glaube ich brauche
erstmal noch ein bisschen Zeit um
überhaupt wieder
so viel Vertrauen da rein zu finden dass
das dann diesmal jetzt aber klappt mein
Freund ich habe einen neuen Freund in
der der will unbedingt eigene Kinder und
der wäre glaube ich auch ein richtig
toller Papa aber ja wir ziehen jetzt
erstmal zusammen und lassen alles ganz
ruhig angehen vielleicht irgendwann dann
schon wie lange hast du gesucht bis du
deinen traumhof gefunden hast das war
tatsächlich der erste Hof der überhaupt
in Frage kam nach drei bis vier Jahren
suche ursprünglich habe ich mit meinem
Ex-Freund zusammen nach einem Hof für
uns alle als Familie gesucht wir haben
so viel angeschaut wir haben so oft eine
Geburt abgegeben und wurden überboten
weil wir immer super viele Mitbewerber
hatten ja und dann haben wir uns
getrennt und dann dachte ich mein Hof
Traum wäre geplatzt weil ich mir nicht
vorstellen konnte dass ich das irgendwie
alleine noch hinkriegen würde dann habe
ich aber auf Youtube davor schon geteilt
dass wir in den Hof suchen und ich habe
auf Youtube nicht gesagt dass ich mich
von meinem Partner getrennt habe
deswegen hat mir dann eine Zuschauerin
gesagt dass sie einen Hof angeschaut hat
der ihr total gut gefallen hat und ihr
aber zu groß ist aber sie glaubt dass
mir der super gut gefallen würde sie hat
mir dann mehrmals glaube ich geschrieben
guck dir den doch mal an und ich war so
ich sehr gibt doch keinen Sinn warum
soll ich mit ihm jetzt noch angucken
aber ich kann das auch jetzt nicht ihr
nicht sagen was los ist und so ja und
dann habe ich gedacht warum fahre ich
nicht einfach mal hin und dann schauen
wir mal wie es da ist das ist ja immer
schön so eine Besichtigung zu machen und
wer weiß dann habe ich mich schon
verliebt und dann habe ich einfach
entschieden dass ich den Hof alleine
kaufe ja das hat sich ziemlich Ärger
angefühlt und ziemlich
wagemutig irgendwie aber gut ich musste
aber auch noch anderthalb Jahre warten
von dem Zeitpunkt an bis jetzt wo wir
bald einziehen können weil die Leute die
den Hof verkaufen einen Haus bauen das
ist halt noch nicht fertig gewesen und
darauf mussten wir noch warten bevor ich
da irgendwas machen kann deswegen hat es
jetzt ewig gedauert diese ganze Suche
mit allem auf jeden Fall ja so um die
fünf Jahre jetzt sind wir endlich da
akzeptiert dein Sohn deinen neuen Freund
ich glaube das ist immer schwierig wenn
man schon ein Kind hat und sich getrennt
hat und dann einen neuen Partner findet
das war auf jeden Fall eine große Sorge
von meinem Freund als wir angefangen
haben uns zu Daten dass mein Sohn ihn
einfach nicht akzeptieren würde oder
dass er in meinem neuen Freund den
Trennungsgrund sehen würde obwohl er das
überhaupt nicht wahr aber solche Sorgen
hat man glaube ich immer und wir hatten
einfach wahnsinnig viel Glück dass die
beiden sich super gut verstehen ich
hatte nicht so große Sorgen weil ich
kenne ja meinen Sohn ich wusste dass er
mein neuen Freund mit offenem Herzen
empfangen würde aber mein Freund war das
auf jeden Fall erstmal sehr aufregend
und eine große Sorge und er hat auch
keine Kinder und es hat alles auch neu
weil ich habe ja meinen Sohn sehr früh
bekommen das heißt die meisten Leute in
meinem Alter fangen ja jetzt gerade erst
vielleicht an äh Babys zu bekommen mein
Sohn ist einfach schon Nein ja das ist
super schön die beiden zu beobachten
wenn die auch mal unter sich sind also
da geht mir regelmäßig das Herz auf und
wenn ich bin sehr gespannt wie das wird
wenn wir dann jetzt alle zusammenziehen
aber ich glaube das wird gut müsst ihr
noch viel sanieren
nicht wirklich also an sich ist das Haus
in einem richtig guten Zustand obwohl es
halt sehr alt ist das einzige wo es ein
bisschen brennt ist die Dämmung also es
ist halt super schlecht gedämmt da
müssen wir auf jeden Fall ran wir wollen
eine Fassade komplett neu dämmen und
auch neu machen leider auch noch Asbest
dran ist das Dachgeschoss wollen wir
dämmen weil der Dachstuhl ist noch
überhaupt nicht gedämmt das sind so zwei
Projekte wo ich hoffe dass wir das vom
Winter noch hinkriegen zumindest den
Dachstuhl mein Fokus ist auf dem Garten
und auch bei allen Besichtigungen war
mir das Haus ehrlich gesagt relativ egal
ich will einen schönen großen Garten und
den kriegen wir auf jeden Fall und das
Haus ist auch gut wie ist es eine Firma
rund um dich zu führen also das andere
in deinem Namen Arbeiten am Anfang war
es richtig komisch für mich Chefin zu
sein weil ich da Anfang 20 war und nicht
wirklich ich bin jetzt auch noch nicht
so so eine Business-Frau oder irgendwie
oder so eine typische Chefin also es ist
zum Glück auch so dass die Leute die bei
uns im Wurzelwerk Team arbeiten
super
umgänglich sind und wir eigentlich alle
sehr familiär miteinander sind und ich
eigentlich nie so die Chefin raushängen
lassen muss und das ist sehr toll und
mittlerweile ist es irgendwie normal das
Leute für mich arbeiten weil ich es
einfach alleine niemals schaffen würde
alles was wir bei Wurzelwerk machen ich
kann euch ja immer einblenden was wir
eigentlich alles machen weil oft sind
Leute super überrascht wenn die mich
kennenlernen und dann dann sage ich dass
ich ja so 14 Mitarbeiterin habe und dann
wird die immer so hä was was machen die
alle den ganzen Tag ah ja dass die
anderen in meinem Namen arbeiten das
fand ich am Anfang vielleicht komisch
also eine der ersten Sachen wo ich mir
gesucht habe war waren meine E-Mails
dass ich die nicht mehr selber
beantworten konnte da unterschreiben die
aber nicht mit Marie und tun so als
wären sie ich sondern sie unterschreiben
mit Franzi Saskia Kathrin und so weiter
wann hast du angefangen zu gärtnern ich
habe mit zehn ungefähr auf der
Dachterrasse meiner Eltern angefangen zu
gärtnern natürlich noch in einem
kleineren Umfang und als wir mit 18 dann
in unsere erste eigene Wohnung gezogen
sind das weiß ich schwanger war und da
sind wir halt von zu Hause ausgezogen in
so eine kleine ein Zimmer Kellerwohnung
und da war ein ganz kleiner
beachstreifen mit dabei und da habe ich
zum ersten Mal dann draußen im Garten
gegessen hat und irgendwie begleitet
mich das Geld dann schon mein Leben lang
und es wird auch nie wieder weggehen
zieht ihr zu dritt auf dem Hof ein ja
mein Freund und ich sind gerade in der
Fernbeziehung und das wird sich bald
ändern der gartengemüsekiosk gemacht ein
Geheimnis aus der Finanzierung ihres
hofprojekts vielleicht kannst du ja
transparenter sein für alle die Wissen
der gartengemüsekiosk ist ein ganz
toller anderer YouTube-Kanal und die
beiden Jenny und ihr Mann haben auch
einen Hof gekauft und ziehen auch
ziemlich zeitgleich jetzt diesen Sommer
dorthin und es sind sehr lustige
parallelen denn und ich sind auch gerade
viel im Austausch das tut sehr gut ich
glaube der Garten gemüsekiosk macht auch
kein Geheimnis daraus dass YouTube ihr
Vollzeitjob ist genauso wie bei mir
deswegen weiß ich nicht ob die
wirklichen Geheimnis draus machen ich
gucke jetzt aber auch nicht jedes Video
an weil mir einfach die Zeit dafür fehlt
deswegen kann ich das nicht so gut sagen
und ich will auch nicht intens Namen
hier irgendwas behaupten ich sage nur
wie es bei mir ist ich mache Wurzelwerk
hauptberuflich und verdienen so mein
Geld mit meinem Blog mit Youtube mit
Instagram mit meinen Kursen wir haben
jetzt ja auch im Garten Online Shop mit
Werkzeugen und sagt gut so verdienen ich
mein Geld wie jeder andere auch nur das
ist halt ein bisschen komischer Job ist
und so viel erzähl ich mir jetzt mit
fast 30
auch langsam mein Haus und mein Hof hat
jetzt auch nicht die Welt gekostet also
das ist jetzt kein Luxus anwesend
mal ehrlich was ist der wahre Grund für
euren Umzug
was ist das für eine Frage ähm der wahre
Grund für unseren Umzug ist das es echt
nervig ist wenn man Selbstversorgung
betreibt und kein eigenes Grundstück hat
das ist möglich und ich mache das ja
jetzt schon ewig lang ungefähr seit 12
bin habe ich ziehen zur Selbstversorgung
und ich bin jetzt 28 und das hat
geklappt ohne dass ich je einen
Quadratmeter eigenes Land besessen habe
und auch meine Gemüsegärten hatte ich
immer auf Grundstücken von anderen
Leuten die die nicht mehr genutzt haben
also es ist möglich aber anstrengend und
das ist der wahre Grund warum für einen
Hof kaufen also ich weiß nicht was für
ein Geheimnis der Fragesteller oder die
Fragestellerin da vermutet aber ich
freue mich einfach
langfristig mal in den Grundstück
investieren zu können weil bisher hat es
immer keinen Sinn ergeben auch nur einen
Obstbaum zu pflanzen wenn man nicht weiß
ob man in zwei drei Jahren überhaupt
noch da wohnen wird und weiß dass man
wenn man auszieht alles wieder zurück
bauen muss in den Originalzustand
hattest du auch schon mal den Moment
kompletter Überforderung wenn plötzlich
alles schief läuft ja in allen
Lebensbereichen würde ich sagen also ich
finde es teilweise sehr herausfordernd
Mutter zu sein alleinerziehend und zu
arbeiten also ich bin nicht komplett
alleinerziehend mein Sohn ist immer zwei
Wochen bei mir und dann zwei Wochen bei
seinem Papa aber in der Zeit wo er bei
mir ist bin ich halt mit ihm alleine und
muss alles irgendwie hinkriegen also das
ist schon teilweise herausfordernd aber
mittlerweile geht es eigentlich ziemlich
gut also wir haben unsere Abläufe mein
Sohn ist mittlerweile echt groß und das
klappt aber z.B auch im Garten habe ich
solche Momente immer wieder gerade jetzt
haben wir einen riesen Rattenproblem die
Ratten haben meine Tomaten Jungpflanzen
jetzt schon zum dritten Mal komplett
über den Boden abgefressen also bei mir
stehen jetzt gerade noch stand heute
sechs Tomatenpflanzen von ungefähr 40
die ich gepflanzt habe und das ist sehr
frustrierend sehr frustrierend also wir
unternehmen was gegen die Ratten aber es
ist so schwer gegen die anzukommen weil
da sind so viele ich habe das auch noch
nie erlebt dass die einfach
Tomatenpflanzen als grün fressen also
letztes Jahr haben die die Früchte von
den Tomatenpflanzen abgefressen aber
jetzt drehen die völlig durch ich kann
das sehr gut nachvollziehen wenn wenn
auch manchmal graue Haare bereitet woher
hast du die tollen Möbel die man ab und
zu im Hintergrund sieht
ich habe ganz viele Möbel aus dem
gebrauchtwarnzentrum also so Antike alte
Sachen diese Kommode hier ist zum
Beispiel richtig alt und ich weiß nicht
ob ihr das seht aber die Schubladen die
haben keinen Scharnier oder wie heißt
das keine
Metalldinger wo das rein und rausgeht
sondern das ist einfach nur Holz auf
Holz und weil das so unglaublich gut
gefertigt ist läuft jetzt immer noch
einwandfrei und sowas finde ich einfach
so schön so richtige Handwerkskunst und
das könnte man ja heutzutage gar nicht
mehr bezahlen wenn man das neu
anfertigen lassen würde deswegen habe
ich sehr viele alte Vollholzmöbel
einfach von Ebay oder vom
gebrauchtwagenzentrum würdest du mich
hundertprozentig im Homeoffice
einstellen also das kam mehrere solche
Fragen auch braucht ihr noch
Unterstützung im Team also es ist
richtig süß dass ihr bei uns mitmachen
wollt das freut mich immer wir freuen
uns auch immer über Bewerbungen einfach
per E-Mail initiativ im Moment haben wir
eigentlich nur eine Stelle offen wo wir
jemanden suchen und das ist für
Marketing weil Marketing bisher immer
hinten runter fällt bei mir das einfach
überhaupt nicht liegt jetzt irgendwie
was verkaufen zu wollen aber wir ja
darauf angewiesen sind weil das unser
Job ist und wir unsere Brötchen bezahlen
müssen und deswegen brauchen wir nachher
dringend hilfe ich wünsche mir da
jemanden der halt nicht den Leuten
irgendwas aufdrückt was sie überhaupt
nicht haben wollen sondern auf eine
charmante und eine angenehme Art
Marketing machen möchte also wenn sich
jemand da draußen auskennt mit Online
Marketing wir haben den Onlineshop und
wir verkaufen online Kurse dann ähm
schreibt uns an diese E-Mail-Adresse
sind und es geht auf jeden Fall im
Homeoffice wir haben zwar ein tolles
Büro hier in der Nähe von Kassel aber
man kann ja so einen Job auch komplett
im Homeoffice machen und ab und zu
kommen dann mal alle zusammen und dann
freuen uns und und Grillen zusammen oder
machen Ausflüge also schreibt uns
einfach mal gucken was draußen wie oft
gehst du deine Tomaten im Gewächshaus äh
erstaunlich wenig also viele Freunde von
mir die auch Gärtner sind immer
überrascht wie wenig ich die gieße ich
mache das so ungefähr einmal in der
Woche man muss dabei aber aufpassen das
funktioniert nur wenn man gut mulmigt
das ist ja sowieso immer mein Credo in
meinen Videos wo ich es einfach super
wichtig wenn man Wasser sparen will und
in diesem trockenen Sommern sollten wir
alle versuchen Wasser zu sparen meine
Tomatenpflanzen kommen damit relativ gut
klar dass ich nur einmal in der Woche
gieße das ist aber halt auch eine
Erziehungsfrage also wenn man jeden Tag
liest dann gewöhnen sie sich natürlich
auch daran dass sie immer Wasser
bekommen und Wurzeln gar nicht so tief
dann ist es so eine Sache wenn man
unregelmäßig gießt so wie ich dann
können die Pflanzen Probleme bekommen
wie z.B die blütenendfäule kann dadurch
entstehen oder Tomaten können auch
aufplatzen wenn die plötzlich so viel
Wasser bekommen dann platzen die Früchte
teilweise auf also wenn man damit
Probleme hat dann heißt das dass man
doch eher ein bisschen enger Takten
sollte wie oft man gießt aber das muss
man eben bei sich ausprobieren und wenn
man sieht das Probleme auftauchen und
dann halt vielleicht ein bisschen öfter
Gießen ich finde es toll wenn du uns
beim Umzug mit nimmst
Gartenprojekte die wo was rund ums Haus
ja das ist auch eine Frage die ich mich
äh mir stelle ich habe schon mal auf
Instagram nachgefragt aber möchtet ihr
Videos rund um den Hof sehen wo du
vielleicht auch mal mehr um die Tiere
geht um einen Stall den wir ausbauen um
Renovierungsarbeiten also interessiert
euch das auch wenn das ein bisschen
anders ist als die gartenvideos die ich
meistens mache oder habt ihr da kein
Interesse dran also schreibt mir das
gerne mal weil ich mich das auch frage
weil ich werde jetzt erstmal zwar den
alten Garten noch ein bisschen behalten
bis alles abgeerntet ist dann wird es
auf jeden Fall bis März dauern bis ich
wieder einen neuen Garten habe weil ich
den erst umgestalten will über den
Winter und ich weiß gar nicht was ich
dann Filmen soll aber ich könnte
natürlich ganz viel Hof Content machen
und immer mal wieder sich auch Balkon
Videos wir haben ja auch diesen tollen
Balkon jetzt gestaltet und im alten
Garten kann ich auch noch ein bisschen
Filmen aber ja schreibt mir mal ob euch
das interessiert und um den Umzug in den
Hof jetzt kommt die Frage von der ich
mich gefühlt habe es gab schon mal einen
Shop für Gartenartikel war der von
deinem Ex damit meinte den Garten
Gorilla Shop da habe ich ja auch schon
mehrere Videos zu gemacht ich glaube die
ganz neuen Zuschauer wissen das nicht
aber
ähm vor ein paar Jahren vor zwei Jahren
habe ich mit jemand anderem schon mal
einen gartenshop aufgebaut und jetzt
habe ich eben meinen eigenen gartenshop
und das war damals auch nicht mein Shop
sondern das war von einem guten Freund
von mir der hat als internationales
Model gearbeitet und dann kam Corona und
er hat auf einmal keine Arbeit mehr
gehabt und
sah es ziemlich in der Patsche und dann
hat er eben erzählt dass er in den
gartenshop aufbauen würde und da dachte
ich mir wow das ist so cool weil ich
bisher immer auf Amazon verlinken musste
wenn ich euch irgendwas empfehlen wollte
und das das fühlt sich nicht gut an weil
Amazon halt so ein Konzern ist deswegen
haben wir uns gedacht ich könnte ihm ja
sagen welche Sachen ich empfehlen möchte
dann kauft er die eine und ich kann auf
ihn verlinken und verdienen da meine
ferienprovision so heißt das das ist als
Youtuberin ziemlich großes Standbein wo
man relativ doll darauf angewiesen ist
dass man halt empfehlungs links setzt
wenn man denn was zu empfehlen hat was
ich irgendwie auch anbietet weil ihr
fragt ja auch immer nach was ich so
benutze das heißt ich wollte nicht ganz
auf dieses Standbein verzichten aber ich
wollte auch nicht weiter Amazon
unterstützen und deswegen habe ich dann
immer auf gartengorilla verlinkt das war
ja lange Zeit mein bester Freund und das
ist auch sehr schwer darüber zu reden
und ich werde auch nicht so viel darüber
erzählen aber genau wir waren auch
früher mal in der Liebesbeziehung und
daher gab es ja auch tausend
Spekulationen drüber ähm ich glaube das
merkt man auch weil wir einfach uns sehr
vertraut sind miteinander genau aber das
ist halt schon sehr lange her es kam
auch so viele Kommentare dazu wie man
denn mit einem Mann einfach so
befreundet sein kann und ich glaube sehr
wohl dass das funktioniert und das ist
bei uns auch deswegen so gut
funktioniert hat weil wir diese ganze
diese ganze liebes Ding ist alles
romantische hatten wir schon mal durch
und es war einfach so klar dass das
nicht funktioniert und das macht sehr
leicht wenn man jemanden trotzdem mag
einfach nur mit ihm befreundet zu sein
ohne dass man irgendeinen Hintergedanken
hat auch wenn die armen armen einschläft
also das war einfach eine sehr wichtige
und tolle Freundschaft für mich wir
waren irgendwann nicht mehr auf einer
Wellenlänge was den Shop angeht also
sowohl die Preise da bin ich einfach
nicht mehr mitgegangen weil ich die zu
hoch fand und dann auch keine Lust hatte
mehr euch dahin zu schicken weil ich
euch gegenüber dann einfach so ein
schlechtes Gefühl hatte weil ich wusste
die Preise sind einfach zu hoch und das
ist nicht fair für euch und das war halt
für mich auch ein riesen Zwiespalt weil
ich wollte natürlich auch mein Freund
unterstützen aber das hat sich
irgendwann einfach nicht mehr gut
angefühlt deswegen bin ich sehr froh
dass ich jetzt meinen eigenen Job habe
und da einfach machen kann was ich will
ja das ist ein sehr abenteuerliches
tolles neues Projekt aber ich habe auch
so ein weinendes Auge weil ich weiß dass
das mit dem Garten Gorilla Shop einfach
überhaupt nicht so gelaufen ist wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe und ich habe
auch daraus gelernt dass ich nie wieder
mit Freunden Geschäfte machen möchte
weil das Potenzial dass die Freundschaft
daran kaputt geht einfach sehr sehr groß
ist und das ist das ist nicht wert wo
kaufst du deine Kleidung ich ich kaufe
das allermeiste secondhand ein weil und
damit mache ich mich jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen unbeliebt also ich möchte
halt gerne nachhaltige Kleidung
einkaufen aber ich finde das Fairtrade
Bio Kleidung oft einfach nicht so schön
ist also mir gefallen die Sachen oft
einfach nicht und deswegen schaue ich
lieber im Secondhandladen z.B das Kleid
was ich jetzt anhabe das hat meine Mama
in der verschenke Kiste auf der Straße
gefunden und mir ein Foto geschickt und
ich meinte ja ja
richtig gut genau so hat sich
wahrscheinlich zu 90% meines
Kleiderschranks nach 100 zusammen
gesammelt aber für euch wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen schade weil oft fragen
Leute wo hast du das Kleid her und so
weiter und ich kann es euch nicht sagen
weil die Sachen die gibt's eh nicht mehr
aber ich finde secondhand Kleidung auch
viel cooler weil da muss es gar nicht
erst hergestellt werden ist noch viel
besser als Bio oder Fairtrade wie dick
sollte ich im Blumentopf Mulchen weil
ich empfehle ja auf 10 bis 20 cm im
Garten je nach Kultur und das geht ja am
Blumentopf nicht deswegen mulche ich ihr
Blumentopf so ungefähr 3 cm was halt
noch oben rein passt Mulchen ist im
Blumentopf aber super wichtig weil in
Töpfen ja noch viel mehr Wasser
verdunstet also man muss viel öfter
gießen wenn man im topfgärtnert der
Mulch bedeckt den Boden und schützt den
vor Verdunstung dadurch kann man eben
viel mehr Wasser speichern also wenn ihr
im Kopf geht nicht dann muss ich auf
jeden Fall was wolltest du früher werden
von Beruf ich wollte immer Roman Autorin
werden schon seit ich klein war ich habe
ja mittlerweile ein Buch geschrieben
sogar Spiegel Bestseller Platz eins aber
einen Sachbuch das heißt
Selbstversorgung mir ist immer noch der
Traum einen Roman zu schreiben riesig
groß und ich habe früher ja jede freie
Minute damit verbracht in meinem
Notizbuch zu krebseln oder an meinem
Laptop zu sitzen und Geschichten zu
schreiben und ich war da so drin und
seitdem ich so viel arbeite komme ich
einfach nicht mehr dazu also ich
schreibe manchmal Geschichten für meinen
Freund für mein Freund für meinen Sohn
und jetzt z.B schreibe ich gerade eine
drachengeschichte für meinen Sohn hat
auch nur wenn irgendwie mal irgendwo
Zeit ist und ja meistens kriegt er dann
zu Weihnachten oder zum Geburtstag eine
handgeschriebene Geschichte von mir aber
ich würde so gerne irgendwann an den
Punkt kommen dass ich dafür wieder mehr
Zeit habe und ich weiß wenn ich mich nur
tief genug rein Knie dass ich dann auch
im Buch schreiben kann was
veröffentlicht wird weil das ist ja auch
immer nicht so einfach aber ich weiß
dass das ist möglich ist ich ich spüre
das in mir Zeit nur wenn du magst jetzt
kommt wieder so eine Frage wie trennt
man sich mit Kind ich hoffe irgendwie
dass alle Eltern die sich trennen das
wohl das Kindes als allererstes in ihrem
Kopf haben weil Kinder da so drunter
leiden können wenn sich die Eltern
Fetzen ich habe schon lange überlegt
mich zu trennen bevor ich dann gemacht
habe weil man sich das eben tausendmal
überlegt wenn man Kind hat und will dass
das eine schöne Familie hat aber
irgendwann ja ich wusste es eigentlich
schon länger aber irgendwann habe ich
mich dann getraut und und das war auch
alles am Anfang schrecklich und ich habe
so viel geweint und es hat mir so leid
getan auch für meinen damaligen Freund
und das ist echt hart er hat nichts
falsch gemacht oder so und ich habe ihm
nichts vorgeworfen und er hat mir nichts
vorgeworfen und das ist glaube ich eine
gute Voraussetzung weil sowas so schnell
überlagern kann wie man sich dem Kind
gegenüber verhält und es geht einfach
nicht man muss dann erwachsen sein man
muss dann die eigenen Befindlichkeiten
runterschlucken und irgendwie mit dem
Partner klarkommen außer er hat halt was
wenn er jetzt gewalttätig ist dann
natürlich nicht da muss man vielleicht
einfach das Kind nehmen und abhauen hast
z.B auf meinem Sohn geholfen hat der
fand das natürlich am Anfang total
schlimm und hat immer gesagt nein ihr
dürft nicht auseinanderziehen
war dass wir am Anfang noch das nächste
Modell hatten also das Kind ist in einer
Wohnung geblieben und wir waren immer
abwechselnd da das war aber für uns als
Eltern total schwierig dann habe ich mir
eine eigene Wohnung gesucht und was da
auch geholfen hat war dass ich meinen
Sohn gesagt habe guck mal jetzt hast du
zwei Kinderzimmer und wie sollen wir das
denn einrichten haben uns eben auf diese
positiven Sachen fokussiert und dann
zusammen irgendwie das Kinderzimmer
schön gemacht er brauchte dann natürlich
auch neue Spielsachen das war natürlich
auch total toll sich dann zu überlegen
was hat er denn noch nicht nicht das
Kind jetzt irgendwie mit Geschenken
glücklich machen aber irgendwie so den
Fokus auf die positiven Sachen zu lenken
das hat auf jeden Fall bei uns ein
bisschen geholfen aber ich glaube das
ist für jede Familie einfach super hart
und wir hatten es da noch relativ leicht
ich verstehe absolut wenn du es nicht
teilen willst aber wie viel hat der Hof
ungefähr gekostet die Frage kam so oft
ihr seid einfach unverschämt sowas sagt
doch nicht ich glaube ich kann darüber
schon einigermaßen offen reden auf
Instagram das war ganz interessant kam
ein ganz schöner Shitstorm nachdem ich
gesagt habe dass ich einen Hof gekauft
habe weil sehr viele Leute meinten ja
einen Hof kriegt man ja heutzutage nicht
mehr unter einer Million einfach gerade
so in der wirtschaftlichen Lage in der
wir uns befinden gibt es einfach viele
Menschen die gerade sehr große
Schwierigkeiten haben überhaupt ihren
alltäglichen Mist zu bezahlen und
einkaufen zu gehen und gescheites Essen
auf dem Tisch zu bringen und das kann
ich auch sehr gut verstehen dass man
dann wenn man im Internet jemand sieht
der sich dann so einen Traum
verwirklichen kann dass das erstmal
einem aufstößt wie gesagt ich habe den
Hof ja vor anderthalb Jahren gekauft
also da war die Lage auch noch viel
entspannter ja der Hof ist wie gesagt
jetzt kein Luxus Anwesen ich kann euch
ja mal sagen wie das so abgelaufen ist
also als ich den Hof angeschaut habe
haben die Besitzer gesagt dass sie von
250.000 hätten und da war mir schon klar
weil ich ja schon lange auf der Suche
war dass der Hof deutlich mehr wert ist
da war ich erstmal sehr happy und dachte
mir oh das ist das ist ja machbar und
dann gab es so viele Interessenten für
den Hof dass die Besitzer gesagt haben
wir machen jetzt eine Bieterrunde ist ja
auch total verständlich dann war ich so
unsicher was ich bieten soll bei
einerseits gab es diesen vergleichsweise
niedrigen Einstiegspreis den sie genannt
hatten andererseits wusste ich aber dass
eigentlich alle vergleichbaren Hilfe die
ich gesehen habe mindestens 500.000
gekostet hätten das war was was ich
einfach nicht ausgeben wollte für den
Hof deswegen habe ich eine ganz krumme
zeige boten die irgendwie in mir war
nämlich 336.000 und ich habe ganz knapp
ganz knapp die bitter runter gewonnen
hinter dem zweiten bietenden also das
war irgendwie so eine
bauchgefühlsentscheidung es ist einfach
Wirklichkeit geworden so jetzt wisst ihr
wenn ihr noch mehr Fragen habt
unangenehme oder angenehme Fragen dann
schreibt sie gerne unten rein in die
Kommentare dann kann ich beim nächsten
Q&A da mal reinschauen und mir da welche
rauspicken und ansonsten verlinke ich
euch da drüben das letzte
Q&A was ich gemacht habe wo ich zum
Beispiel über mein Burnout gesprochen
habe solche schöne Sachen dann geht raus
und macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner
und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video
wieder